[Music]
do you find yourself arguing with
strangers on the internet all the time
have you recently eradicated an old
friend or family member from your life
because they keep posting wrong ideas
ask your doctor if steel manning the
other side is right for you
seal manning the other side is the
latest breakthrough in cognitive
technology to help those suffering from
algorithmically amplified rage and
hatred
we took the tried and tested method of
steel manning where you use the
strongest arguments you can think of to
fight for your own point of view
and then applied that same methodology
to the other side's point of view as
well to the people who we disagree with
since i started steel manning the other
side i became so much better at
understanding why some people think
differently to me i don't always end up
agreeing with their conclusions but at
least now i can empathize with why
they're acting this way hey aunt sally
yeah
i know it's been a while yes well anyway
i just wanted to say i've been thinking
about it and i realized you might not be
sitting incarnate after all
yeah
our natural tendency to fall into
ideological tribalism is currently being
exploited for profit by fast media
corporations and that is why we're
seeing this epidemic of r that we're
seeing today so talk to your doctor
about how steel manning the other side
could help you
because life doesn't have to be this way
[Music]
steel manning the other side is safe to
be used by anyone regardless of age
gender or political comorbidities side
effects include but not limited to
reduce blood pressure clear thinking
more diverse friend group a longer
tension span have your family gatherings
more time for physical activity greater
empathy increased focus and deeper
understanding of the world and better
informed decisions